by now I assume most of you have seen
the boo bits from Dragon Ball Zia bridge
that has been released uh but did you
happen to notice that the colors looked
I don't know a little bit better than
what you're used to Let's dive in to see
how that came about so long story short
every home release in existence of
Dragon Ball Z has colors that have
degraded over the decades which means
suddenly everyone is a pink monster or a
green monster or well you know you get
the idea when we partnered with TFS for
those boo bits we offered to help
manually color correct the clips to
bring them back to how they originally
looked on TV when they aired the
comparisons you've been seeing on screen
are some before and afters the befores
are what TFS edited up themselves and
The Afters are the product of a
wonderful manual color correction by
friend of the channel banson so yeah
pretty cool so much hard work went into
these bits that went on notice so here's
me shining some light on it for you all